ces apiculteurs du yucatan se sont
regroupés pour améliorer leur production
de miel leur coopérative financé par
l'état se consacre à la production de
rennes d'abeilles italienne sans aucun
produit chimique
la production changer les rênes améliore
la production et diminue l'agressivité
des abeilles elles produisent plus de
miel et du miel de meilleure qualité
parce que les pays importateurs comme
l'allemagne la grande-bretagne les
etats-unis tolèrent de moins en moins
les produits chimiques et vol de
l'organique
les mexicains même maya ne sont pas de
gros consommateurs de miel mais ce sont
de gros producteurs et exportateurs
cinquième au monde avec une industrie
concentrés dans la péninsule du yucatan
or les petits producteurs se plaignent
ils sont 3000 dans la région et trouve
que l'industrie ne valorise pas assez
leur miel
l'entrepôt tout neuf est presque prêt à
recevoir le miel des associés ce qu'ils
veulent tous et le proclame bien fort
équitable et biologique et sur 57 mille
tonnes de miel produit chaque année au
mexique 10 % seulement sont biologiques
et les clients étrangers détecte de plus
en plus de traces d'eau gm et de
pesticides dans le miel mexicain
les abeilles souffre de désordres
organique elles ont du mal à ingérer le
nectar et ensuite elle meurt en cause la
déforestation
début décembre la récolte du soja se
termine les fermiers sont des mennonites
originaire du manitoba il avait émigré
en 1917 pour fuir l'école obligatoire le
mexique les avait alors accueilli dans
l'état voisin de chihuahua infligé de
sécheresse chronique
il y a une dizaine d'années l'état de
campêche et au yucatan plus humide leur
a proposé de bonnes terres à bon prix
mais il fallait des boisés ce qu'ils ont
fait massivement en dix ans la péninsule
du yucatan a perdu plus de 80 mille
hectares de forêts selon globo forestois
plus de la moitié dans l'état de camper
tchéou se sont multipliées les champs de
maïs et de soja depuis 2010 la culture
du soja est passée de 7000 à 165 mille
hectares selon les chiffres du ministère
de l'agriculture et 80% de ces terres
appartiennent à des ménages
c'est une communauté moderne connectée
par internet à la bourse de chicago
seuls les vêtements de ses femmes et
enfants trahissent leur origine
traditionalistes
en 2012 des apiculteurs maya avec à leur
tête cette femme lydie pécs
des abeilles mais l'ippon sont partis en
guerre contre l' écriture ogm des grands
agriculteurs leurs abeilles mouraient
par millions les mennonites ont vite été
montré du doigt les apiculteurs mayas
ont gagné leur bataille juridique contre
les ogm de monsanto devenu bayer en 2017
en principe les ogm sont interdits mais
il reste des doutes pas d' ogm chez nous
affirme cornier lieu slovène
on a essayé les ogm sur le maïs mais ça
n'a pas marché par contre le glyphosate
impossible de s'en passer
le glyphosate eu les mauvaises herbes
mais avant la somme aille une fois le
chanceux mais il ne reste plus nous
sommes pas entièrement bio mais nous
utilisons très peu de produits chimiques
les ruches de la communauté en forêts
alentours des champs sont en bonne santé
santarossa qu'empêcher nous avons
importé un plan de soja de santa rosa à
l'agronome
ce soja n'est pas transgénique
affirme-t-il les mennonites travaille
bien
mais il est clair que la moitié des
semences disponibles sont transgénique
parce qu'il n'y en a pas assez naturel
et c'est la faute du gouvernement
mexicain qui en a le contrôle
le sénateur aurait carlos la mairesse
marine a basé toute sa récente campagne
électorale sur le thème de la protection
des abeilles
c'est
d'abord les abeilles puis c'est la
civilisation qui va disparaître et la
planète terre habermas ban appelle nos
agriculteurs qui déboisent pour produire
plus vont devoir dépenser plus sans
pollinisation des abeilles pollinisent
jusqu'à 75 % des plantes les natives
comme la mairie paul vont polliniser les
espèces natives de la forêt maya et donc
la préserver le sénateur se donne comme
objectif de faire connaître les
particularités des miels mexicain par le
gouvernement et surtout mettre un terme
à la déforestation de la péninsule du
yucatan enfin appliquer strictement
l'interdiction des ogm et limiter
l'usagé de pesticides